this is an egg but then you already knew
that
you know because eggs have been central
to human existence for thousands of
years in fact you'd probably take it for
granted after all sent you an egg but if
you're prepared to look closer to see
through its calcium carbonate shell
you'll find a microcosm of the universe
now believe me this started the
beginning the very beginning several
religions multiple traditions the
ancient Egyptians the Greeks the Romans
the Incas all have eggs at the heart of
their creation stories in Southern
California the origin story of the kulli
have people lichens the creation of the
entire universe to the cracking of an
egg a little further east
of Nebraska and Iowa spoke of egg being
dropped into the world's oceans
protected by a bird serpent inside this
egg lay sleeping all of the mothers and
all of the fathers of everyone yet to be
born but these are stories where the
science in 2006 data gathered by NASA's
Wilkinson satellite suggested that the
universe itself may be an ellipsoid an
oval egg-shaped
the science community remain unable to
categorically prove or disprove this
theory but it remains possible we're all
living inside a massive ever-expanding
egg in 1609 Johannes Kepler confirmed
the planets including our own go around
the Sun not in a perfect circle but in
an elliptical orbit the moon's
elliptical orbit that makes it appear to
regularly change size in the night sky
without this egg-shaped dance I may seem
far less interesting
far from being smooth an eggshell is
more like the surface of the Moon bumpy
and grainy in texture a single eggshell
is covered in up to 17,000 tiny craters
but it's also semi permeable allowing
air and moisture to pass through it this
remarkable shape not only is it possibly
the shape of the actual universe it's
sort of the pinnacle of architectural
design here is a structure with no
internal solid support and yet it's
strong enough to protect and nurture
life itself inside if one point of the
shell is put under external force the
stress is distributed evenly across the
entire dome which is why you can't crush
an egg with the palm of your hand but
how to replicate nature's perfect
aerodynamic design an egg has no obvious
beginning or end so where didn't even
start it wasn't until the 20th century
that human architects started to get the
hang of building egg like structures on
a grand scale the egg in Beijing seats
five thousand four hundred and fifty two
people in three halls and is more than a
thousand square meters in size
that's one seriously big egg legend the
size of the earth club eggs have
inspired artists from Dali to fabergé
and made memorable movie cameos
sigourney weaver's hall 212 packing
ghosts
Paul Newman 1850 in Cool Hand Luke and
John Hurt or in final
particularly nasty one an ATM in
Gulliver's Travels when the people of
Lilliput went to war with their
neighbors it was over which way round -
it's a boiled egg could somebody please
untie me on instagram we liked this egg
in greater numbers than we'd liked
anything else ever before mr. strong a
nothing but eggs which actually was not
a bad idea an X protein that the perfect
mix of amino acids required to build
human tissue
second only to our mother's milk eggs
have also whisked their way into our
everyday Lexington I'm not joking let me
egg-splain people can be good eggs or
bad eggs if you're particularly smart an
expert in your chosen field perhaps you
might be called an egghead we send our
kids on egg hunts we scramble we poach
we bake if you want to make an omelet we
all know what to do not knowing how to
boil an egg is considered shorthand for
soy who can't cook and yet when
searching how to boil an egg Google will
offer up millions billions odds perhaps
it's not as simple as we thought once
like the egg itself people have been
welcoming spring by decorating eggs with
bright colors since the Middle Ages but
join Cadbury didn't make his first
chocolate egg until 1875 18 million
chocolate eggs are now sold every year
in the UK alone the Eric child
these eight
but Easter it seems the egg will always
come first but then of course you
already knew that
[Music]